when it debuts on may 3rd 2019 the
fourth avengers movie will be tasked
with accomplishing an unprecedented
defeat in cinematic storytelling
tying up one of the most sprawling sagas
in movie history
but all signs point to one certainty it
will pull it off in style
tony's last stand considering the end
credit scenes of infinity war a lot of
speculation over the pending defeat of
the mad titan thanos has centered on the
space fairing captain marvel
carol danvers but comments made by the
directing team of the russo brothers
have heavily implied that the good
captain won't necessarily be a magic
bullet the biggest threat to thanos may
be none other than
iron man as infinity war detailed thanos
and tony are on a first name basis with
both of them holding deep-seated grudges
over
the first avengers battle of new york
while captain marvel's power level will
surely play a part in thanos defeat it
makes more sense that stark who kicked
off the entire mcu will be forced into a
final showdown with thanos
one way or another it's probably the
last time we'll see robert downey jr in
the role
but does the encounter have to end with
his death it's never been more plausible
expiring contracts not only would a
clash between iron man and thanos in
which stark meets his demise make
narrative sense
it would also make business sense robert
downey jr's contract with marvel will be
completed with avengers 4
and he's not the only one whose time is
up while everyone who is snapped away in
infinity war
is probably coming back the fates of the
original team members are much more up
in the air
we know that avengers 4 will also
complete the contracts of chris evans
chris hemsworth and jeremy renner the
status of mark ruffalo's deal is unknown
and though scarlett johansson is on
board for a black widow solo feature
there's no guarantee that that film will
take place in the post avengers 4
timeline
meaning she could be done for as well
there's a reason the original crew
survived thanos big snapping
for the old school members of the team
avengers 4 is one
last ride end of the guardians the
guardians of the galaxy series quickly
became one of the mcu's most
cherished series thanks to its
adventurous tone and characters that are
outlandish yet relatable
their crossover with the avengers in
infinity war was long awaited and even
though they mostly turn to dust by the
end of that film
dave bautista has confirmed the team
will appear in avengers 4.
however disney's firing of writer
director james gunn and subsequent
decision to put guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 on hold has thrown the entire
future of the team into question
and it's even been speculated that
avengers form may be reworked during
reshoots to phase out gunn's version of
the team permanently
for all we know avengers 4 will be the
last time we see the guardians
something that used to seem unthinkable
returning favorites
infinity war saw many of our heroes
being reduced to dust but the fates of
more than a few popular characters
remained up in the air
luckily many of their actors involved
with the movie seem to have difficulty
keeping their mouths shut clueing us
into a few significant characters who
survived thanos snap
in an interview with screen rant during
the promotion cycle for mission
impossible fallout
angela bassett let slip that not only
did her character raimonda survive
so did her genius daughter shuri could
she take up the mantle of black panther
while her brother is away
instagram detectives were also able to
all but confirm that tessa thompson's
valkyrie will also be back after sitting
out infinity war
but no sleuthing was required to
determine the fate of wong the trusted
companion of doctor strange
the character's actor benedict wong just
went ahead and posted a photo of himself
on set
his return will be welcomed but that
skull peeling photo has prompted wild
speculation from fans that huang just
might
turn out to be a scroll one of the
shape-shifting alien baddies will be
introduced to
in captain marvel a cosmic culmination
infinity war took the saga of the
avengers to new heights dramatically
raising the stakes of the conflict with
thanos by having the mad titan
actually succeed in his genocidal
mission but avengers 4 will give us
something that the marvel cinematic
universe hasn't had to face until now
a conclusion according to marvel studios
mastermind kevin feige
avengers 4 the 22nd entry in the mcu
will completely wrap up the 10 years
worth of story that started unfolding
with 2008's iron man
he acknowledged that the individual
movies within the mcu are perpetually in
motion
always leaving viewers on the hook for a
sequel of some sort this time he says
will be refreshingly different we're in
the end game now
uncharted territory seasoned fans of the
mcu know that the studio has never
directly adapted a story from the comics
but rather used marvel's decades of
print storylines for inspiration
the most obvious example of this is
captain america civil war which took its
title from a famous story arc while
sharing only a few basic plot points
with its namesake
infinity war is a loose adaptation of
the comics infinity gauntlet story
but marvel isn't dipping into its back
catalog for avengers 4
according to directors joe and anthony
russo it will be a totally original
story
joe russo told comicbook.com i have no
interest
as a director in telling a story that's
already been told or in seeing one
that's already been told
if i know all the events of the story as
they're going to happen then what's the
point of going to the film
it's a good point and one which means
that fans looking to marvel comics for
clues to the conflict's outcome
probably aren't going to find them comic
readers saw thanos snap coming from
miles away
but what comes after nobody knows
thor speaks if you're looking for
general reassurance that avengers 4 will
blow your mind just as hard as infinity
war look no further than the words of
the odin son himself
chris hemsworth speaking in an interview
with esquire the actor revealed his
opinion that avengers 4 will outdo its
predecessor when it comes to unexpected
surprises
saying if you were shocked by infinity
war i think the second one is
even more shocking for other reasons
entirely the second one i'm probably
even more excited about
while we're curious about where the
story will go assurances like this are
almost as good
whatever happens we're happy to let the
wild speculation continue until the
movie's release
at least until mark ruffalo comes around
and spoils the entire thing for us
wait till you see this next one
everybody dies
dude not everybody
[Music]